francisco es de los que cree que nada es
imposible hasta que deja de ser posible
sin pensarlo dos veces reunió su equipo
de rescatistas voluntarios y junto a su
perro rastreador flash vinieron hasta
beirut para hacer lo mejor que saben
rescatar bueno estando en chile y
después de haber visto las tremendas
imágenes y como de horas imágenes de la
explosión y teniendo una primera
impresión respecto a 300 o quizás más
personas desaparecidas y asumiendo que
somos un grupo de busca y rescate nos
pusimos a disposición del gobierno
libanés y obviamente empezamos a
trabajar con toda nuestra nuestra
logística y nuestra tecnología la
tremenda explosión en el puerto de
beirut dejó una destrucción incalculable
tanto en términos materiales como de
vidas humanas ante tanta desolación
todos los esfuerzos se unen y desaparece
la barrera del idioma entre los equipos
de rescate locales extranjeros
la que agradecemos los esfuerzos de
nuestros colegas chilenos y de otros
países que han venido a ayudarnos en
este desastre hablamos de un solo idioma
y somos un solo equipo porque trabajamos
al mismo nivel y con el mismo objetivo
buscar y rescatar a los supervivientes
un mes después de la explosión este
equipo de chilenos trajo de vuelta la
esperanza a una población destrozada de
encontrar sobrevivientes bajo los
escombros una ilusión que se desvaneció
con rapidez pero que dio muestra de que
son de estos suramericanos y los llevó a
ganarse la cercanía y el cariño de los
vecinos de mar mijael este barrio tan
afectado por el desastre hoy día el
éxito de la misión implica el no
encontrar a alguien porque
necesariamente para nosotros implica que
nadie está sufriendo ni nadie falleció
bajo este contexto nosotros nos vemos a
las víctimas como un trofeo ni como una
medalla que tenemos que ganarnos cada
vez que vamos un rescate las labores
humanitarias de rescate de los topos han
puesto de manifiesto que el líbano
necesita más allá de las ayudas
económicas dosis de esperanza y luz al
final del túnel para poder superar estos
momentos tan oscuros